All right, so in this small lecture, I'm gonna tell you how you guys you to you can utilize the silver bullet with the
External and internal liquidity method. All right
So we're gonna start off on the 15 minute time frame if you're gonna take your entry on one minute and
On one hour time frame if you're gonna take your entry on the five minute time frame, okay
So let's suppose that we're gonna take our entries on the one minute because as
I see he has taught himself you can take your entries on one minute or five minute. It doesn't matter
so let's say that we are on the 15 minutes, right and the
the I see the silver bullet timings are three to four and ten to eleven am right New York time
So let's suppose that before ten, right?
Or even after ten right you have a purge on the external so let's say at nine fifty nine thirty
You have a purge and you have a fairly gap
Where is it dude, okay, you have a fairly gap in the discount, right?
You want to wait for a shift in the market structure, right?
The shift in market structure can happen before
940 before 10 right it can happen at 949 50 doesn't matter as
long as this internal liquidity is intact your draw is gonna be this so let's say
First let's talk about the first scenario, right? You drop down to one minute now. You get a market structure shift entry beautiful. I
Mean don't target this just go for one to two
But there's another scenario where this market structure happens market structure happens
before ten right and you get let's say a
Push down another break of structure and that's when when you have this break of structure, right?
Oops my bad
That's when the silver bullet timing start and you have a fairly gap here
You are going to take that entry from that fairly gap because we know our drawn liquidity is here
So take that trade very simple. We go from external to internal
Your entry must be at 10 after 10 right of the fairly gap that forms after break of structure or
displacement
But I would suggest that you look for a market structure shift after 10 right or
Let's say you have this level here price goes up gives you a shift in structure your entry is at 10
This the first move is always hyperbole now in this case
You can look for that second distribution entry as well on the one minute time frame, right?
So you can get a purge here, right? And once you get a purge you look for a
Double break of structure, right
You can get a double record check that you can take your entry from that fairly gap
So that is going to like increase your silver bullet wind rate to like like it's going to increase it by a lot
So yeah, that's that's about it. Let me give you guys
And an example and then we'll move on to the last lecture, which is going to be how to pass your prop from challenges